[Music]
[Applause]
the most
obvious difference between the two
versions of the film is the tone there's
so many examples i could use to
illustrate this but even the
opening seconds of the film clue us into
how wildly different each of these films
are going to be
in terms of how they frame their stories
tone is constructed through a lot of
different elements of the filmmaking how
you light a scene makes a difference
weed and re-shot scenes like this one in
the airplane
the lighting of the original snyder
version is just way
more moody and whedon's shooting stuff a
lot more
like a comedy and we see more of the
image more clearly that has an effect
on tone it's already here for the same
shots how they're color graded affects
tone the choice of music is a big
element
[Music]
even the choice of a prop like a shovel
can affect the tone of the film
in this video i'm going to go into all
those little differences in the
filmmaking of the two versions of
justice league how they differ
and how those differences affect tone
pacing
and ultimately the overall experience of
watching the film
thanks to mubi for sponsoring this video
[Music]
well i think the snyder cut is a far
from perfect film i found it way more
compelling
entertaining and interesting than the
original which honestly kind of
bored me out of my mind but i wanted to
know why
what exactly were the differences and
why did i
enjoy the snyder cut so much more i
watched the two films back to back and
then loaded them into my editor to see
exactly how much overlap and how many
differences there were
snyder was already a significant way
into the production
of justice league when joss whedon was
brought on by the studio
to try to make some changes that they
wanted snyder had to step away and
whedon
ended up finishing the film what we're
getting to see now
is the snyder cut which is what snyder
originally intended for the film to be
plus about 70 million dollars of
additional shooting
whedon's version has about 16 scenes
that are re-shot he also added about
seven
new scenes that aren't in the snyder cut
at all there are about 22 scenes that
are in both films but are just edited
differently and about 24 scenes that are
in the snyder cut that aren't in the
weeding cut
at all but it's not about tallying up
all the little differences in terms of
plot or content what i want to focus on
are the smaller changes that affect the
film's
pace tone and story this is not a
discussion
of how each of these films treat the
superhero lore
or toxic fandoms or the drama behind the
scenes i want to play film detective to
find out exactly why i liked one of
these so much more
and bring you along for the ride to see
what we can learn along the way
let's break down a scene and see how
several different elements can work
together to affect the tone
in both versions of this scene aquaman
has rescued a guy from a shipwreck
he drops him off at a pub asks for a
whiskey grabs the whole bottle and walks
away
diving into the sea but the tone and
therefore what each scene
represents for the character and the
story is radically different
in the original justice league this
moment is kind of like
[Music]
and in this version it's
struggling fighting his inner demons and
you know
pushing through it or something like
that you could argue about which of
these is better which
sets up the character better i think the
tone of the song that snyder chooses
fits sort of the aesthetic of what's on
screen
a lot better but if we look back earlier
in the scene we can see that the way the
scene is cut
also affects the tone in the snyder cut
the representation of aquaman as
brooding and melancholic
is bolstered by the bartender's reaction
to him
and his awkward walk to the door the
weeding cut avoids this
using either a different take or recut
to portray aquaman as more confident
and also gives the scene more energy by
adding a smash cut to bring in the music
i think it's pretty clear that a lot of
the motivation behind the changes that
were made for the weed inversion were
made
to try to change the film's tone they
went to great lengths to try to do this
some of the more
ridiculous examples include changing the
design of the drawing of the parademons
or replacing the skull
on the screen and flash's lair with a
k-pop music video i guess
besides these aesthetic elements
obviously a big part of
establishing a tone also comes down to
the
writing of scenes and dialogue you had
enough to deal with don't need to add
mother-in-law to the list
but i found a little place that suits me
just fine right by the diner
i'm not here for help whedon is
reshooting scenes or adding in lines
that are more jokey
and uh
you're gorgeous and fierce and strong
i don't think really a lot of these land
okay but so far i've only shown that the
tone is different
in the snyder cut none of this explains
why
it's better snyder's darker brooding
moody tone has often been criticized in
the past
and warner brothers dc as a studio have
kind of
wanted to potentially lean away from
this like overly brooding like
dark tone that snyder has brought to a
lot of these films part of what the
studio on
seems like whedon was trying to do was
to
sort of change the tone honestly into
something a little more marvelous
the way i see it there's not an
objectively best tone like
light and fun isn't somehow objectively
better than like moody
and dark as an individual you might
prefer a lighter or darker tone
personally but what i think is the most
important in telling an effective story
is having a tone that is consistent and
one that
matches with the story you're trying to
tell in the original version
the tone just feels forced because well
it is
it really clashes with the existing
material that's there
and what you end up with is a movie that
has scenes like this
kalel no
right along scenes like this this
janitor's wife had some strong words for
the aliens
she says stole her man if whedon had
maybe been trying to make
his version of this movie from the start
maybe a lighter more fun tone would have
worked
but this attempt to sort of force a lot
of what
snyder had already done into the box of
being a fun film
it wasn't working that's not to say
snyder's tone is perfect there
are still places where the tone feels a
little weird or over the top to me
but it actually feels like a movie that
knows what it wants to
feel like and come across as rather than
the original which just
felt like an attempt to copy paste an
avengers
color grade over top of an existing
moody film
i also think it just speaks to this
weird debate about tone
that i think completely misses the point
of dc
versus marvel films i think a lot of
fans and
the studio themselves misidentified the
difference between these films as
primarily a tonal one i mean the tones
are definitely different but the reason
the marvel films are more successful
is because they've generally been better
made more entertaining
better written films they just also
happen to have a lighter tone
but because that's an easy to spot
difference between the two
it's something fans complain about when
the dc films aren't as good
and then the studio thinks hey if we
just make it have a lighter tone
it'll do better the dark knight has one
of the darkest tones of
any superhero film and it's one of the
most popular you don't achieve marvel's
success by just
mimicking their tone you do it by
telling stories that are
as engaging and entertaining to your
audience
take a look at both versions of the
scene that introduces wonder woman
and pay attention to the differences in
pacing the first thing you'll notice
comparing the two is just how much
longer the lead up to the action is in
the snyder cut by the time the van has
pulled up to the building in the snyder
cut in the original the baddie is
already out of the van and has shot
through
several victims the basic structure of
the scene is the same in both versions
the terrorists come in
takes some hostages wonder woman is
introduced and then she saves the day
but the original cuts four minutes out
of the scene over half its original
length
and it does so without sacrificing any
plot information
which works if your goal is simply to
cut down the running time
so while what's cut doesn't affect the
clarity of what's going on
it does dramatically affect how the
scene feels
this time spent on the long walk up to
where the hostages are in the snyder cut
that is mostly trimmed out of the
original it might feel unnecessary but
that extra
minute of building tension and danger
before wonder woman is introduced
creates suspense and makes it more
impactful when she is revealed and in
the snyder cut after we see wonder woman
we go back inside the building spending
some time with the bad guys and in the
perspective of the hostages again
it further builds suspense because now
we're waiting to see
when and where wonder woman will step in
in the original wonder woman is revealed
and then she just immediately gets to
work and saves the day
and all the tension is lost the scene is
reduced to its most
fundamental action and plot points the
snyder cut also contains
this moment which helps humanize and
develop wonder woman as a character a
bit
something she's really lacking in the
original this pattern kind of replicates
itself throughout a lot of the scenes
that are in both films
and in some scenes it's not even a an
instance of
taking out big chunks of the scene it's
just trimming every shot like a little
bit so that it flows
faster
[Music]
it's clear from both behind the scenes
reports and just seeing the two versions
side by side
that a big priority for the studio was
reducing the running time
instead of aiming for the running time
that was necessary to convey
the story they were trying to tell the
studio had a goal of achieving a
specific running time and in the process
of cutting all that material
down to the running time they wanted
they ended up pacing the film too
quickly and removing a lot of the stuff
that makes it an
enjoyable engaging film it's about
finding the pace that's right for the
story you're trying to tell for justice
league there's a lot going on the script
is written as a sort of epic there are a
lot of characters that need to be
introduced
a lot of moving pieces in the plot and
slowing down the pace helps us
understand all of these things and feel
their significance
here's an example would you like to have
some uh no thank you
if you put the water in first of course
so we don't a little scene between
wonder woman and alfred about having tea
might feel inconsequential and
unimportant but
it has an impact on how we perceive the
story
first it develops their characters a
little bit seeing them do something
mundane and relatable makes them feel
more human
second it indicates the passage of time
seeing the characters killing time and
doing something that
isn't directly related to advancing the
plot
makes it feel like there's story
happening while we're not around
watching this adds to the film's sense
of scale and actually makes it feel like
it's taking a while for
this team to assemble it's not just
something that happens overnight
the biggest issue with the original is
the fact that they just tried to force a
running time onto
a story that was meant to be much longer
they did attempt to rewrite and cut some
things out so that the story fit into
the shorter running time
but i don't think they did enough most
of the time when it's a scene that shows
up in both versions i like the version
that's in the snyder cut a lot more in
the
original justice league it just feels
like a montage where we're jumping from
one thing to the next as quickly as
possible now i can't talk about pacing
and give the snyder cut a free pass the
snyder cut has pacing issues
in a different way the original tries to
do too much in too little time and the
snyder cut tries to do too much
in too much time i personally like the
snyder cut better because
i think it contains the elements that
are necessary for the story to feel
significant
emotional and for there to actually be
some suspense and tension but it also
contains a lot of additional clutter
that does distract from the best
elements of the film
in terms of both pacing and running time
i think the best version of this film
overall
would land somewhere in between the two
all of this pacing is coming from
basically differences in the editing and
the editing in the two films is not that
dramatically different
outside of the pacing most of the places
you're pulling from the same footage to
edit the scene so it's not like in the
original
whedon cut the scenes are you know using
dramatically different angles or
anything like that mostly it's the same
camera angles being used
it's just tighter pacing cutting through
things cutting
out anything that's unnecessary to the
plot
there are definitely some instances
where different shots are used however
here editing is being used to manage the
tone
the snyder cut is darker we see the
violence in a little bit
more of a visceral way and the weeding
cut kind of tries to avoid that we stay
on the villain's face and we don't see
who he's shooting
and so here editing is being used to
kind of manage the tone as well and try
to keep the film
a little bit lighter in the original cut
the resurrection of superman shows how
even small changes can have a big impact
on how significant
the scene feels here's how they raise
the idea in the original
if you were in a conductive field boost
from the mother box
could bring him back to life it's just
kind of tossed out as an idea
here's snyder's cut i know we're all
thinking the same thing right now
who's gonna say it i'm not gonna say it
maybe a little bit overly dramatic but
you get the idea
it feels more important more epic more
significant
one of the things that bothered me about
the original is that this moment
felt a little anticlimactic and
[Music]
insignificant
and in the snyder cut i think it hits
much harder
there's also a big difference in how
they set up the stakes at the moment
of revival as a viewer you kind of know
that it's
already going to work so you have to
infuse this scene with
some kind of drama in the original
there's just a general sense that things
might go wrong
aquaman literally says this is crazy
and this is a bad idea but we don't
really have an idea
of why the only real conflict here is
the setup that you have to charge it the
moment it touches the fluid which is
just kind of
lame and a little trite and weakens the
scene compare that to the snyder cut
where the heroes need to resurrect
superman but they know using the cube
risks action is summoning steppenwolf
who's afraid you're no stupid wolf will
come forward you know that already
continued
it creates a possible cost to their
actions and they're willing to pay that
on top of that the conflict with flash
shifts from
he needs to time things just right too
he's pushing his abilities
to their utter limit i don't like to
break this rule but when i approach the
speed of light i
look crazy things happen to time but if
i do it i create massive electrical
power
which feels more significant and also
plays into a payoff that comes at the
end of the film
as superman is being revived it's
intercut with these scenes of
lois lane kind of going about her life
and then we get this moment where
she sees him and this creates an
emotional arc for this section these
moments are all cut out of the original
and you can cut those out because like
technically they're they're not
really important to the plot lois lane
like doing stuff going about her day
leading up to this moment
it doesn't affect the plot but there's
more that's important to a
interesting entertaining film than just
like the step-by-step
beats of the plot we need emotion one of
the ways to generate emotion is reaction
and so if you have this character there
we
see how they're reacting and responding
feels more emotional
one of the things that i really didn't
like about the original cut was just i
never felt connected
to any of the characters they didn't
seem very human
i didn't have time to really connect
with their emotions
there wasn't much backstory involved
here and you can launch some of those
complaints still about the snyder cut
but you definitely get
way more of this kind of thing in the
snyder cut and i think a lot of that
just has to do with the fact that there
is
more room to breathe you're actually
spending some
time with the characters a great example
of this is
cyborg and his relationship with his
father we get all this detail
about his backstory then there's a
subplot with his father who ends up
sacrificing himself and it gives the
character a little bit of an
emotional arc there's actually some
emotion some personal human backstory
happening here
and this just all gets cut out in
the original i think it's also worth
saying that the snyder cut does
push this stuff like too far in some
cases like when we're setting up the
backstory for cyborg we probably don't
need the
hugely dramatic scene of bulls fighting
to represent the stock market
the world's monetary systems and its
complex interactions will seem as easy
to manipulate for you
and the scene where he's like hacking an
atm to give money to a poor family
those both kind of establish the same
thing and it's a little redundant and
the movie's four hours long so
overall i'd rather have a little bit too
much development so that i actually
become invested in the characters
than none at all like we see in the
original
let me show you a cool example that
shows just how significantly
context and setup can impact our
perception of a moment by looking at the
scene where the heroes fight together
for the first time
so going into a scene like this you have
the conflict of
the heroes are teaming up for the first
time and they're trying to go in and
take out this target
but what makes a scene like this even
more interesting
is if you give it additional layers of
conflict and
both films do this but differently in
the
snyder cut we have cyborg cyborg's dad
is in with the hostages and so there's
this
emotional conflict within cyborg
they are trying to not attack
individually they want to work all
together
but cyborg ends up breaking that rule
because
he wants to save his dad help his dad in
the
whedon version since the story line
between cyborg and his dead has kind of
been cut out i'm assuming they kind of
reshoot or add in this element of the
flash being
nervous about whether or not he's going
to be
useful full transparency i've never done
battle
i've just pushed some people and run
away save one
what this affects the way we see the two
scenes
when i watch the original version
this moment felt very significant it
felt like sort of
the culmination of his arc for the scene
because
he was in conflict am i going to be able
to be helpful and then
super stylized fashion he's shown being
helpful and it sort of resolves the arc
of that conflict
in the snyder cut we don't have that
setup and so when you get to this moment
it's just a little bit of
a cool thing the last thing i have to
say about stakes is to address one of
the few things that was actually added
in the weeding cut
which is this russian family that lives
near where the baddies hive has been
established
normally i would applaud the motivation
behind something like this
one of my complaints about a lot of
superhero films
is that the stakes feel very distant
from the
reality of saving real people in the
world
in the snyder cut we don't get a visible
sense that there are real people
in danger there's mostly this abstract
concept of evil looming threatening to
destroy the planet
so in theory having something like this
family should help the stakes feel more
human immediate and relatable except
that it doesn't because it's so clearly
just a patched in attempt to try
to do just that since it was added in
after the fact nothing that's going on
with this family feels like it was
connected to
anything else and the payoff just ends
up being a lame moment
and a cheap joke this is a great example
of the solution
being worse than the problem i love the
idea of trying to
add a more human pedestrian element to
make things more relatable and the
stakes
more immediate but how you do something
often matters just as much or more than
what you do
in a film
i think of my notes i have written down
for this scene real
cornfield like here
the cornfield they're standing in to me
actually feels like real
in the snyder cut in the weed and cut
the original it just
just feels fake for whatever reason
whether it's just
bad taste on joss whedon's part or
whether it's
just that he had less money or was
working quickly
a lot of the reshoots that he's doing
that are in the original justice league
are just
not well done the quality of the writing
is low
quality the quality of the cg
is is lower this also applies to the bad
guy
like this version just looks like a bad
video game character to me and this
version looks more real
a little more sinister even hey we need
a scene with some exposition to patch in
this scene that we
cut out for time and so it's like oh
instead of
going to an inventive location or
something interesting
we'll just shoot gal gadot and ben
affleck like walking beside a lake or
something
i understand why the snyder cut is four
hours long don't get me wrong snyder had
the opportunity
to release his cut shoot some additional
material and just put out whatever he
wanted
for the fans and he took it but i'm
trying to evaluate this
as just a film and take it out of the
context
as sort of a pop culture lore
collectible item
and i know a lot of people love the fact
that a certain someone shows up but when
i look at the film
as a contained story i often wonder
what on earth is this scene even doing
here so that's my best shot at
diagnosing the technical reasons why i
think the snyder cut is so much better
on
a lot of levels if i had to actually
give my review of the snyder cut i don't
think i could say it better than
rich from red letter media zack snyder's
cut of the justice league is an
unbutchered mess that's true while
watching six hours of justice league
material was a nice diversion for a week
i think i've reached
my quota of superhero stuff for at least
two years now so it's back to talking
about bergman and whatever
else it is i do on a regular basis if
you're like me you want to break and you
want to explore some
other kinds of film i recommend you pick
out something to watch on mubi
i recently watched dark star a
documentary about the artist h.r geiger
who designed the xenomorphs for the
alien films
you could check out that or you could
check out the holy mountain
which like the justice league is about a
group of people who come together to
honestly it's nothing like the justice
league and it's probably nothing like
anything else you will ever watch and
that's what i love about mubi here
you'll find
fascinating interesting stuff that it's
difficult or impossible sometimes to
find
anywhere else and that's because they
have a team of people
hand-picking interesting stuff for you
to watch on their platform right now my
list of stuff that i want to watch on
there is getting so long it's kind of
getting out of hand
so if you want to expand your exposure
to international art house and classic
films with access to a library that's
hand curated and is updated daily give
mooby a try by going to mubi.com
thomasflight
click the link in the description or go
to mubi.com
thomasflight that'll give you an
extended 30-day free trial when you sign
up for free
to try mubi thank you so much for
watching and a huge
thank you to my patrons who really help
support my channel and what i'm doing
when you become a patron you can get
access to
additional content i make i do a podcast
every month where i talk about what i've
been watching
i make bonus review videos where i let
my patrons
choose a movie for me to watch every
month and then i review it there's a
discord where you can ask me questions
hang out and discuss things
learn how you can become a patron and
join the community by going to
patreon.com
thomasflight